the General Affairs Council on Tuesday
in Luxembourg will begin its meeting by
discussing enlargement and the
stabilisation and association process in
particular whether to grant candidate
status to Albania in December the
council invited the Commission to report
as soon as the necessary progress had
been achieved also taking into account
the further action taken by Albania to
fight corruption and organized crime the
council will also discuss the
preparations for the upcoming European
Council meeting at the end of June which
will focus on three main areas security
and justice growth and jobs climate and
energy as well as external relations
issues such as the situation in Ukraine
ministers will also adopt the EU
maritime security strategy which aims at
protecting the maritime security
interests of the EU and its member
states against common risks and threats
such as piracy and terrorism or
organized seaborne crime and trafficking
ministers will also discuss the EU
strategy for the adriatic and Ionian
region